How did the villain in Wakanda Forever
steal the show? And what was the biggest
complaint about the movie? Keep
watching for what critics are
saying about the latest installment
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Going into this film, many MCU fans
were wondering how it would handle
the death of Chadwick Boseman.
We can't give anything away,
but Twitter reactions are proving Ryan Coogler
honored his friend properly. One critic tweeted,
Another agreed, adding,
A major theme being discussed on Twitter
is the world-building Coogler managed
to cram in the film's two-hour and
41-minute runtime. Wakanda Forever
introduces the underwater nation
of Talokan, where Namor reigns.
It certainly is not easy to introduce a whole
new world in the MCU, especially within a movie
focused on Wakanda and its people. One
critic wrote that Wakanda Forever is a,
quote, "solid mix of developing [a] post-Chadwick
path, plus world-building for future MCU stories."
Wakanda Forever is certainly an emotional outing,
but Twitter reviews suggest it's so much more
than a legacy film. It's also a throwback to
the great films of The Infinity Saga,
including the original Black Panther.
"Show them who we are."
Finding a Wakanda Forever tweet that doesn't
praise Angela Bassett is like finding a needle
in a haystack. The Academy Award nominee,
who played Queen Ramonda might get another
nod thrown her way at the next Oscars if Twitter
has anything to say about it. One critic tweeted,
"Have I not given everything?"
Another shining star in Wakanda
Forever is Tenoch Huerta,
who is getting ample amounts of praise
on social media. A critic wrote,
Another added,
Wright also gets lots of compliments on
Twitter, with a film YouTuber writing,
If the tweets surrounding Wakanda
Forever are any indication,
this might just be the best film in Phase 4
of the MCU. It will likely battle Spider-Man:
No Way Home in debates about the best, but if
you're looking for a solid, well-rounded film
that doesn't rely on fanfare and cameos, the
Black Panther sequel looks to take the cake.
Perhaps one of the biggest talking
points amongst moviegoers is Namor,
as the MCU's newest villain is a scene-stealer.
After seeing the flick Thursday, a viewer wrote,
"He's coming for the surface world."
Someone else agreed, writing,
"But my enemies call me Namor."
The MCU has always had something of a
villain problem. Sure, there are some greats,
but a majority of the Marvel antagonists have
been either relatively dull or total duds that
lack the complexity of the movies' good guys. It
looks like Namor is helping to balance it all out,
as the character is being hailed as one of
the film's highlights. Another viewer tweeted,
If you scan the Wakanda Forever tweets,
you'll notice one theme more than any
other — the movie perfectly honors
Chadwick Boseman. There are hundreds
upon hundreds of tweets mentioning the
late actor and how the film pays its
respects to him. One person said they became
emotional during their screening, writing,
Someone else agreed, tweeting,
Like we said earlier, don't forget
those tissues before sitting down for
Wakanda Forever. Many tweets indicate the
film is a tear-jerker, with one reading,
"We had been kinda, in a way, we had been keeping him alive by working on the film."
Of course, there were criticisms.
You can't please everyone these days,
especially movie fans. While it's difficult to
find a tweet that totally bashes Wakanda Forever,
there are plenty that point out
its flaws, with one viewer writing,
When it comes to the not-so-glowing
comments about the movie, it looks
like a lot of moviegoers thought the 161-minute
runtime was just too much. Someone else wrote,
Another viewer agreed, adding,
If the biggest complaint people have about Wakanda
Forever is that it's a little bit too
long, we'd say it's still a winner.